was jetzt
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute spielen wir wie
ihr seht von hear this is one of timo ja
aber nicht ein klassisches woanders ist
wann wir spielen heute zwei first to
five aber mit einer besonderen challenge
und zwar muss der gewinner der runde
nachdem er die runde gewonnen hat ein t
shirt anziehen
ich habe hier fünf t shirts und ich habe
dort mit dabei seit ewigkeiten mal
wieder am start vor sich sehr nicht mal
wieder stimme zu hören hier ja da sind
die shirts und ja der gewinner der
gewinner der jeweiligen runde zieht ein
shirt an dadurch wird natürlich deutlich
schwieriger die späteren runden auch
noch zu gewinnen
ich bin sehr gespannt wie sich das
entwickelt tom ist ready alles klar ich
kenne dich und dann geht ab und runde
eins so leute die erste runde es geht
los
wie nennen wir das kind wird das ja was
denn los
aber ich darf ja eigentlich auch gar
nicht eigentlich will ich gar nicht er
nicht gewinnen ja ich gewinnen ist ein
zweischneidiges schnell also hat
natürlich den ersten gewinn von
firstfive so ist es klar fragt was sehr
wohl alter [ __ ] da hab ich in die tag
wissen zu spät eingesetzt aber okay dann
muss sie jetzt ich gehe mal ein erstes
stellt anziehen ist alles taktisch leute
wisst ja hier wird so getan als würde
mich aufregen dass ich es ohne forlan
aber jetzt wenn der titel an hat dann
machen dann gewicht testing service
engelke jetzt doch lieber dazu moral
lancaster gezogen
natürlich alles in der doppelten face
camp nou nummer zwei und es geht los
du bist doch bestimmt scharf auf ein
weiteres t shirt direkt los übrigens ne
ja ich muss an meine ich kann das geht
doch gar nicht hier lass mich da aber
ich kenne es ja auch nicht dass ein
branding kids hast du bist ok
das sind doch auf dem kiez mein lieber
tomtom places combo das gibt es ja nicht
er kann sehr kleinen sängern ein
besseres schwert inventare ich sag's dir
nur mal okay noch ein bisschen gleich
sind hier aber das müsste ich eigentlich
doch gewinnen oder ich brenne scheiß
nicht kommen
ok ja wissen einschärfen vier eisen
schwer mit dem schnee
das knapp barceló nein ach so ok dann
greife ich jetzt auch nicht anders da
kann es mal görler darf nicht das
durchschnittsalter sehr schön da wartet
tatsächlich okay leute und jetzt heißt
erstes t shirt für mich drüber
den pulli aus na ich heute noch gerade
nicht also leute was auch immer jetzt
gerade sagt falls es hört vertrauten ich
abonniert t shirt angezogen
so stand 1 1 ein bisschen alter dann
nach der 10 final fight beide 4 t shirts
so leute runde nummer 33 jetzt steht
eins zu eins nach dem ich damals gerade
geholt haben beide ein
ach ja also breit aber nicht übertreiben
ich gleich in der pvp master
sportiv guten bogen gehe dann bist du
gar nicht so scheiße ich kann ich nicht
hätten alles klärchen darauf habe ich
gefühl wohliger ja das lama placement
ich glaub ich bisschen ärger macht
plus.de bord ich glaube ich leute
nächste titel für mich steht 2 2 1 und
das meine ganzen sport übrigens diese
ewig warten auch hier sorgten die
facetime bei adidas gibt wieder gas
kohle okay doch ich hör dich so hallo
ich in so leute t shirt ist angezogen
wir springen in die vierte runde für
runde vier ich habe zwei t-shirts an dem
einst es steht 2 1 für mich wenn ich bei
ok dann lasst uns loslegen
klar das mag ich an das schönste weise
games like genau hin zu weicher jetzt
die chest welchem es gibt ja die pvp
alter durch durch zudem sind ja das wäre
ein geworden leute sein drittes tor für
mich stellt drei zu eins kam mein kind
mein kind war das
so dumm ich höre ich wieder und damit
leute drei zu eins ab in die fünfte
runde
so leute 105 es steht 3 1 für mich das
heißt ich habe drei teams an dem 1 und
wir legen los kann man so schön ist
direkt teilung alles klar dass ich mich
jetzt so ich weiß nicht so was ist nicht
so meins ich bin am liebsten mit dem
bistro live hd kit da wollte er glaube
ich die lava places kann das alles
genießen wollen nein kann das etwa sein
dass er da eine la platzieren wollte
mich halt nicht daran
ich habe glaube ich ein bisschen mehr
schaden gemacht ich sollte diese haben
ein bisschen glaube ich habe das
richtige
dann habe ich vier stücke an leute um
darf jetzt wieder kurz fluchen und zwar
genau jetzt ein karabiner warum liegt
ein karabiner auf meinen das was jetzt
leute 410 überleitung in die sechste
runde
so leute die keine runde ich habe vier
tickets an dem 1 4 zu 1 für mich wenn
ich diese runde gewinne dann habe ich
die challenge gewonnen ich habe vier
fucking t shirts an die vier habe ich
extra angezogen ist jetzt fünf an
insgesamt gott der dich jetzt kurz mal
ein blackout
irgendwie kann man ja unter fallenden us
kontingents glaube die question of the
questions ist jetzt wer kann am besten
die damage porschen platzieren wir beide
sehr gut gemacht glaube ich ja aktuell
auch eine eingesetzt jetzt geht's vom
band sie hatte ich so wäre dass du so
wenig leben
ich hab's mir halbes leben abgezogen
damit glaube ich beschließe ich dachte
du fällst runter geht es mir auf einmal
eine 3er combo ich denke so okay mein
letztes stündlein hat geschlagen
auf einmal bist du einfach tot hast du
mich wohl es auseinandergenommen jetzt
die poetischen die kam unerwartet
irgendwie da kam ich zufrieden kann ich
irgendwie macht er erst gegen im lake
gaming bin ich so auf drei herzen bin
dachte ich irgendwie dann kann es immer
so dass ging dann läuft man weg kassiert
noch 242 weglaufen so leute das war's so
weit von dieser challenge in first of
five falls ihr bock an diesen vorfall
und mehr davon haben wollt dann lasst
gerne weiter und schreibt es vor allem
in die kommentare und ganz ganz ganz
wichtig oben belegt den dom abchecken
das unter der beschreibung verlinkt teil
ein sehr sehr guter pvp spreche nicht
dass ich ihn schlagen würde
netto auch ich schon eine besser ist es
auch viel mehr
naja ich nicht mehr bin ich besser du
bist vor allem urgestein doch unbedingt
checken mit dem wie früher viel gemacht
und ja